Neutron stars are the densest things that are not black holes in
that. Cause we might find the most dangerous substance in existence.
Strange matter, a bizarre thing.
So extreme that it bends the rules of the universe and could infect and
destroy everything it comes into contact with.
Or it could teach us about how the universe began. Maybe both.
[Inaudible].
To understand how extreme strange matter already is.
We first need to get a few basics.
What is a neutron star and how does strange matter break the rules of the
universe to get all of this into one video will grossly oversimplify a few
things, but we'll provide you with further reading. If you want more details.
A neutron star is what remains after a very massive star explodes in a
supernova. When this happens,
the stars core collapses under its own gravity with such a strong inward force
that it squeezes nuclear and particles together,
violently electrons are pushed into protons.
So they merge and turn into neutrons.
All that nothing inside of atoms is suddenly completely filled with particles
that really don't want to be close to each other, but have no choice.
They desperately pushed back against gravity against the collapse.
If gravity wins, they will become a black hole. If they win,
they become a neutron star.
This makes neutron stars like giant atomic nuclei, the size of a city,
but holding the mass of our sun and here things get weird.
The environment in the core of neutron stars is so extreme that the rules of
nuclear physics change,
and this could lead to a strange and extremely dangerous substance,
but let's not get ahead of ourselves.
We first need to know the rules before we learn how they can be broken protons
and neutrons.
The particles making up the nuclei of atoms are made up of smaller particles
called quarks. Quarks really don't want to be alone.
They are what we call confined. You can try to separate them,
but the harder you pull, the harder they try to pull themselves back together.
If you use a lot of energy, they just use this energy to create new quarks.
Quarks only exist together as the building blocks of other particles and have
never been observed by themselves. They come in many types,
but only to appear to make stable matter.
The up and down quarks found in protons and neutrons.
All other quarks seem to decay away quickly,
but this may be different insight. Neutron stars,
the forces operating in their cores are so extreme that they are actually
similar to the universe shortly after the big bang neutron star
cores are like fossils, which can let us pair back in time to the beginning.
Everything.
So learning how quarks behave inside a neutron star is a way of understanding.
The very nature of the universe itself.
One hypothesis is that inside a neutron star core protons and neutrons
de confined all the particles creme shoulder to shoulder dissolve and melt into
a sort of bath of quarks.
Uncountable numbers of particles become one giant thing made purely from
qual quark matter a star matron.
This is called a quark star though from the outside.
It may not look any different than a regular neutron star.
Now we can finally talk about the most dangerous substance.
If the pressure inside a quark star is great enough,
it may get stranger literally in the cause of
neutron stars. Some of the quarks may be converted into strange quarks,
strange quarks have bizarre nuclear properties and they are heavier.
And for the lack of a better, the word stronger, if they turn up,
they could eight strange matter,
strange matter might be the ideal state of matter, perfectly dense,
perfectly stable.
Indestructable more stable than any other matter in the universe.
So stable that it can exist outside neutron stars.
If this is the case, we have a problem.
It might be infectious piece of matter.
It touches might be so impressed by its stability that it would immediately turn
it into strange matter to protons and neutrons would dissolve and
become part of the Quock box math,
which frees energy and creates more strange matter.
The only way to get rid of it would be to throw it into a black. But then again,
who cares? All of it is inside neutron stars,
except when neutron stars collide with other neutron stars or black holes.
They spew out tremendous amounts of their insights.
Some of which could include little droplets of strange matter called strange
lights. Strange lids are as dense as the core of a neutron star.
They could be really small, maybe even subatomic,
but even the largest strange lights wouldn't be any bigger than a rocket.
These strange lids would drift through the galaxy for millions or billions of
years until they meet a star or planet by chance.
If one were to strike earth,
it would immediately start converting it into strange matter.
The more it converts, the more it would grow.
Ultimately all of the atoms making up earth would be converted.
Earth would become a hot clump of strange matter. The size of an asteroid.
If a strange lit strikes the sun,
it would collapse into a strange star eating through it like fire through a dry
forest. This would not change the sun's mass much,
but it would become way less bright.
So earth would freeze to death and like a tiny virus we'd have no way
to see a stranger coming.
We're still some theories suggest strange lifts are more than common
outnumbering, all stars in the galaxy.
The strange leads could have formed very early after the big bang when it was as
hot and dense as a neutron star core everywhere,
they might be clumping around the gravity of galaxies as the universe expanded
and evolved.
Strangely it's could even be so numerous and massive that they might actually be
the dark matter. We suspect holds galaxies together. But then again,
maybe not, this is speculation and the earth and sun and planets.
Haven't been consumed in a wildfire of strange lights in the past few billion
years. So the odds seem good that it won't happen anytime soon,
understanding these strange objects today,
maybe the key to understanding the birth of our universe and why it grew to look
the way it does. Now.
When scientists first started playing with magnets and whys and thinking about
electrons,
they had no idea how technology would evolve in the next hundred years.
The scientists thinking about the cause of neutron stars and strange matter
today may be setting up humans for a future beyond our wildest
imaginations. Oh, maybe not time will tell.
So while you're waiting to see if the universe gets destroyed,
you might still want to find out more about it. We've got you.
Our friends from brilliant can be your insight into a whole world of science,
black holes,
and all brilliant is a website that helps you tackle science in a practical way
with interactive problem solving courses and daily challenges in maths, logic,
condemned, generic.
Each problem gives you all the tools you need to crack complex topics all by
yourself. It's learning by doing, but with your brain instead of your hands,
use your curiosity to get to the bottom of puzzles and causes about things like
classical mechanics, astronomy, gravitational, physics, and much more.
If you click the link in the description or visit brilliant.org/nutshell,
you can sign up for free and learn more things than you can imagine.
And there's an extra perk for quotes cause aren't viewers the first 688 people
to use the link, get 20% off their annual membership,
which lets you view all the daily problems in the archives and unlock every
course. Brilliant helps you end your day, a little smarter.
You might get hooked on the experience.
[Inaudible].